reportada por primera vez ante la
organización mundial de la salud el 24
de noviembre la variante o micro amd del
cobi 19 ha alcanzado al menos 40 países
la mitad de ellos europeos pero que
sabemos el nuevo linaje del coronavirus
en primer lugar que omicron tiene muchas
más mutaciones que la variante delta en
esta imagen creada por investigadores
italianos vemos a un micro con 50
mutaciones al menos 30 de ellas en la
proteína de pico la parte que se une a
las células humanas los expertos afirman
que es probable que la nueva variante se
propague más rápidamente que otras pero
esto aún está sujeto a análisis también
habrá que investigar más para determinar
si o micro en causa enfermedades más
graves
está claro que esta variante es mucho
más contagiosa que la variante delta no
hay ninguna información clínica que nos
diga qué omicron es más peligrosa para
los humanos que la variante delta lo
cual es tranquilizador por el momento
con su lado todavía se desconoce si las
vacunas actuales contra el kobe 19 son
eficaces contra la última variante pero
varias farmacéuticas han empezado a
trabajar en nuevas versiones de sus
vacunas para atacar mejora o micro a
pesar de la atención que ha suscitado
del está sigue siendo en la variante
dominante big horn europa o micro no
debe cambiar nuestras prioridades
actuales las prioridades actuales son
superar el pico de la quinta ola y
comenzar el declive para luego reducir
la circulación lo máximo posible y
llegar a la tasa más baja para enero
febrero y marzo
independientemente de las incógnitas los
centros de control de enfermedades de
eeuu dicen que tenemos las herramientas
necesarias para luchar contra un micro
amp y enfatizan que las vacunas el uso
de mascarillas y las pruebas periódicas
son las mejores formas de protección